in ukraine where fears of a possible
nuclear disaster in ukraine are easing
this morning after a russian attack
started a fire at europe's largest
nuclear power facility last night it
supplies more than one-fifth of the
country's electricity that fire is now
out and the u.n atomic energy agency
says there is no repeat no radiation
leak at the plant in southeastern
ukraine russian forces throughout the
country are pushing harder to take
control of major cities and we are
getting a new look at the war's
devastation of ukrainian neighborhoods
take a look at this drone video showing
apartment blocks outside the capital of
kiev
devastated by shelling and russian air
strikes this morning a presidential
advisor says ukrainian forces have
stopped a russian effort to capture a
port city in the south our charlie dagda
is in key with more on the attack that
put that massive nuclear complex in
jeopardy charlie this could have been
very bad indeed and may still be good
morning to you
good morning tony yeah the russian
defense ministry has confirmed that the
nuclear power plant has been seized by
russian troops it's under their control
that follows a night of fighting during
which an emotional ukrainian president
warned if there is an explosion in that
plant that's the end for everyone
including europe
[Applause]
tracer fire sliced across the sky as
russian firepower took a sinister turn
triggering explosions and alarm after
taking aim and opening fire on the
largest nuclear power plant in europe
ukraine's president called the assault
an act of nuclear terror shelling a
nuclear power plant has drawn
international condemnation the head of
nato saying it just demonstrates
russia's recklessness the nuclear
watchdog the iaea reports there has been
no release of radioactive material and
more importantly the radiation
monitoring systems are fully functional
the attack on the plant is part of
russia's widening and escalating
campaign to destroy the country's
infrastructure
but by the day civilians are paying a
heavy toll
harrowing screams echo in the aftermath
of a russian bombardment on a
residential neighborhood in the northern
city of trinity
president putin says his military is
trying to avoid civilian targets but
miles of sheer destruction of apartment
buildings homes schools across multiple
cities and a death toll climbing into
the thousands tell a different story who
say that
putin is not a war criminal who say that
russia is not bombarding
ukrainian cities russian tanks rolled
through the port city of kurzan now
fully under russian control
in the other strategic port city of
mariopol
heavy fighting has knocked out
electricity and water supplies residents
say the city is surrounded and russian
troops are closing in fast
ukraine soldiers and ordinary citizens
continue to put up fierce resistance to
the advance of russian troops but
they're no match against russia's
superior air power which is why
ukraine's president says if the united
states and nato won't impose a no-fly
zone here at least give me the planes
it feels like the battle is closing in
on the capital two this morning after a
period of relative calm over the past
couple of days there's been a
considerable increase in the sound of
explosions in and around the city
nate
charlie dagoda thank you for your
coverage and please stay safe